Hello, and
welcome to intro to the Linux shell.
I'm Phillip, and in this course you'll
learn the basic of how to use the Linux
shell or a command line environment.
>> And I'm Carl.
The goal of this course is to give
you the basic command line tools
you'll need to start
working with Linux servers.
Now, you might have used
other command lines before.
If you've used JavaScript,
you've probably seen the JavaScript
console in your browser.
Or maybe you've used an interpreter
in Python or another language.
Or perhaps you've used the command
line on your own computer.
>> These are all examples
of command line interfaces.
Command line interfaces all
work in about the same way.
You type in a command then they
system runs those commands and
displays the output then you can
type another command and so on.
>> And the idea of a command line
interface goes back to the mid 20th
century and one of the earliest
ways that people had for
communicating with a computer,
the computer terminal.
Now today, terminal usually
means a piece of software.
But it originally meant
a physical piece of hardware for
interacting with a computer.
Before terminals,
people put programs and
data through computers
using punch cards.
Loading a batch of data into
the computer all at once.
The terminal, by letting a user directly
send commands to a computer program and
immediately see responses was a huge
step forward in user interface.
>> And it's an interface that we're
still using today for a lot of reasons.
A command line interface
is programmable.
It's efficient in terms
of network bandwidth and
you can use the terminal edit files in
the distant system without having to
first copy them to your local machine.
In general, you can be much more
expressive with a text based interface
than you can by just pointing and
clicking.
One of the uses of the shells
is to administer servers.
Machines that might be far
away on the network and
that probably don't have
a graphical environment.
For the rest of this course,
you're going to be working on
a system very much like that.
>> So first, you'll need to set up your
own virtual Linux server to work on.
Fortunately, that's a lot
easier than it sounds like.
So let's get started.